actor comedian musician spider-man
donald glover has many hats but how much
do you really know about this
entertainment icon keep watching for the
untold and surprising truth about donald
glover
while attending nyu donald glover became
a part of derek comedy a sketch comedy
group that performed regularly from 2006
to 2010. it was a formative time for
internet culture and the group took full
advantage of the new medium quickly
achieving widespread notoriety with
their videos it wasn't long before they
racked up a healthy fan base on youtube
with comedic skits gaining national
media attention before parting ways
completely glover joined forces with his
sketch comedy crew and released a
detective comedy feature called mystery
team
derek comedy member dc pearson told
paced magazine that the film was
inspired by the group's collective
appreciation of encyclopedia brown
in 2010 pajiba called the film the smart
kind of dumb and with appearances by the
likes of aubry plaza and bobby moynihan
the comedy's cult status has only grown
over time
donald glover was still living as an r.a
in his nyu dorm when snl alum tina fey
came calling his work with derek comedy
had popped up on her radar and she
actively pursued him to write for her
new nbc comedy 30 rock as fae writes in
her memoir bossypants because he came
from a large family in georgia he was
very helpful in writing for the
character kenneth the page
why did he get this amazing opportunity
faye admitted to the new yorker that
race was a big factor she admired
glover's talent sure but it was nbc's
diversity initiative that made him
affordable or in other words free as
glover told entertainment weekly it just
helped you learn the rules of everything
tina fey taught me how to write but also
about the politics of television in a
tribute to glover for time magazine's
100 most influential issue in 2018 they
wrote he embodies his generation's
belief that people can be whatever they
want and change what it is they want at
any time when you're tired of starring
in a network comedy take a break to
pursue your rap career for a grammy
nomination when you've learned all you
can from acting in other people's movies
sit down and create your own piece of
art
donald glover was raised a jehovah's
witness a religious lifestyle that found
him sheltered from much of what pop
culture had to offer
i was always taught like the world was
kind of a bad place so like whenever
things came in i'd be like yo this is
really dope
looking at him now it's kind of hard to
imagine the lack of music movies and
television in the young lover's life but
that's not for lack of trying
glover would listen to bootleg audio of
simpson's episodes in bed at night once
saw the phantom menace at the movies and
even managed to get away with catching
the odd muppet movie this unique
upbringing shaped glover into the
multi-talented artist he is today and
funny enough his role of troy barnes in
community was the first openly jehovah's
witness character on tv that one's
probably no coincidence
2008 was an interesting time for
television not only was the country
immersed in a presidential election
season members of the writers guild were
on stripe causing scripted episodic tv
to come to a halt as the strike came to
an end rumors suggested that saturday
night live was looking for a new face to
step in as then senator barack obama the
show auditioned a number of performers
for the role including jordan peele
jordan carlos and donald glover it took
a few more years for peel to bring his
obama impersonation to tv with comedy
central's key and peel would glover's
barack impersonation have been worthy of
the late night spotlight it's possible
in the end though lorne michaels gave
saturday night live cast member fred
armisen the role just one year later
glover made his jump from writer to tv
actor with his debut as lovable athlete
troy barnes on dan harmon's cult
favorite sitcom community
good news guys i spent all my money oh
you can't bring that in here yes i can
it's all terrain dummy
glover's breakthrough role was on the
nbc sitcom community but his time as
high school football star turned grade a
weirdo troy barnes was often fraught
behind the scenes not the least of which
was due to the antics of co-star chevy
chase the xsnl cast member has long had
a reputation for being difficult to work
with and fulfilled expectations by
seemingly alienating every member of the
community cast and crew when it came to
glover many of chase's remarks and
off-color jokes had a racial edge to
them and perhaps some professional
jealousy community creator and
showrunner dan harmon told the new
yorker in 2018 chevy was the first to
realize how immensely gifted donald was
and the way he expressed that jealousy
was to throw donald off glover and chase
would both leave the show after a
troubled fourth season although harman
convinced glover to return for a handful
of season 5 episodes there appears to be
no one reason why glover left community
rather it was a combination of factors
including artistic restlessness the
behind-the-scene turmoil of that
previous season and the development of
his fx series atlanta
in 2010 twitter was lit up by a campaign
to get donald glover cast as spider-man
glover himself started the campaign in a
tongue-in-cheek way and even referenced
it by appearing in spider-man pajamas on
an episode of community but the hashtag
donald for spider-man took on a life of
its own comic book writer brian michael
bendis eventually took notice and in
2011 he introduced a new spider-man to
marvel comics ultimates series miles
morales a black and latino teenager at
least partially modeled after glover
referring to that episode of community
bendis told usa today he looked
fantastic i saw him in the costume and
thought i would like to read that book
glover missed out the 2012 sony reboot
the amazing spider-man which used the
peter parker version of the character
but he did voice morales in a two-part
episode of the animated series ultimate
spider-man in 2017 he made his marvel
cinematic universe debut in spider-man
homecoming playing small-time crook
aaron davis known in the comics as the
prowler who also happens to be miles
morales uncle the in-jokes and
references get even more twisted around
in 2018's spider-man into the
spider-verse the reality-hopping
animated film centers on miles morales
and includes a cameo of sorts by glover
as aaron davis can be seen watching the
episode of community that featured
glover dressed as spider-man
by 2012 donald glover had collected an
impressive number of accomplishments
especially for someone who'd had their
big tv break just a few years prior
with all the work he'd put out into the
world by that point he had shown a
proclivity for inducing laughs and
what's the simplest way of doing this
why stand-up comedy of course
in 2010 glover tested the waters with
the half hour special comedy central
presents donald glover it was a time of
transition in between his work on 30
rock and community and the awkwardly
energetic aesthetic he cultivated with
derek comedy was present throughout the
performance just something about men the
second they realize they're crazy it's
like trying to kill everything i love
time to kill it all it's all coming with
me
he followed up this stint with an
hour-long special two years later titled
donald glover weirdo by this point
though he had begun releasing music
under the childish gambino moniker while
joke telling could have remained
fruitful hip hop was calling and it
proved to be an even more worthwhile
venture
when donald glover started making
mixtapes he released them under the rap
name childish gambino it's a colorful
moniker to be sure but what does it mean
glover explained on late night with
jimmy fallon that he acquired the name
from a wu-tang clan name generator he
said and then we're all putting them in
and they're all funny and stuff and then
mine came up and i was like you guys
it's not funny anymore
this is this is something big like i
just really liked it
but what does it actually mean in a 2011
fuse interview glover recalled a
conversation he had with wu tang's rizza
who apparently had some valuable insight
he's like yo it's like the computer had
a brain it's like you're childish but
you could also murder someone
glover was quick to point out that he
wouldn't ever kill anybody instead
summing it all up by saying for me it's
kind of just like silliness and kind of
seriousness
his name may signify a blend of
silliness and seriousness but childish
gambino explored a deeper level of
artistry with 2016's awaken my love as
rolling stone argued in their review of
the grammy-winning album gambino delves
into the kind of grungy stank love that
outcast once indulged in on their magnum
opuses
as gambino's music has continued to
mature donald glover's live performances
have evolved as well it all culminated
in pharaohs a live immersive music
festival that glover devised with
microsoft the four-day event that
transpired in joshua tree california was
crafted for a small group of people and
feature performances by a number of
other musicians
including glover's longtime collaborator
ludwig gorensen as glover told vanity
fair
pharaohs is meant to be a communal space
a place that evolves and reacts to the
culture we're selling real intimacy we
protect the experience and it becomes
something you genuinely share with the
people around you and you take away
something special we're looking at
expanding the world in 2018 there will
be more artists involved
sure enough another pharaoh's event took
place in new zealand in november 2018
what the future holds for glover's mini
festival however remains to be seen
up until 2014 donald glover was pretty
active on social media he regularly
shared humorous thoughts and quips on
twitter and even stirred up rumors about
his mental well-being after a series of
posts on instagram glover explained his
dark instagram admissions by saying i
just wanted to write down my feelings i
definitely was just expressing myself
not long after glover drastically
limited his social media usage he later
told the new yorker i felt like social
media was making me less human and i
already didn't feel that human expanding
on his issue with the internet citing
the lack of personal connectivity glover
admitted to esquire that he largely uses
social media anonymously he said i try
and find subcultures i try and find
communities i talk to people as a
regular person it's the only place you
can be anonymous
curious why donald glover has a mention
in the end credits of black panther it
turns out that he and his brother
stephen stepped in to help punch up some
jokes in director ryan coogler's script
glover told entertainment tonight ryan
was gracious enough to be like will you
take a look at the script which was
really cool marvel locks things down so
we had not as much time as i would have
wanted they had already done a great job
so it was really cool to just get our
fingerprints on there a bit glover has
been known to add some comedy consulting
when time allows it take chance the
rapper for example not only have they
worked on music together but glover gave
the rapper some sketch writing
assistance when he hosted snl in
november of 2017. so i brought a few
sketches by one of them made it i
actually got to give credit to my good
friend donald glover who helped me uh
with the idea
glover's explanation of the vibe of
atlanta to the television critics
association in 2016 was as succinct as
it was difficult to picture i just
wanted to make twin peaks with rappers
twin peaks the surreal david lynch
television series whose central murder
mystery made it an unlikely hit in its
first season seemed like an odd
comparison at the time in fact everyone
expected a comedy more along the lines
of what glover was doing on community
what glover and his collaborators
delivered instead is a comedy in name
only or one that often substitutes
unease and dread for belly laughs glover
stars is earn an aimless man who has
fallen into managing the career of his
cousin alfred a mid-level atlanta rapper
known as paperboy the show is frequently
hilarious but what glover shares with
david lynch is a sense of the uncanny
and the sinister lurking in everyday
life for lynch that everyday life is the
white picket advences of blue velvet or
the quirky logging town of twin peaks
for glover it's the already surreal
world of black life in america and like
fellow comedian turned horror maestro
jordan peele glover understands how
little it takes to tweak the daily
struggles of black americans into
something bizarre and terrifying
atlanta is nominally a comedy and
there's a fair share of humor featured
throughout the series but the subject
matter goes much deeper stylistically
there's nothing else like it on
television chalk that up to the
partnership between donald glover and
director hero mirai who developed their
working relationship during multiple
childish gambino music video shoots
together they have collaborated to make
atlanta the emmy-winning force it is
today not many people know though that
the show's aesthetic comes from a short
film that mirai and glover made in 2013.
as mirai told esquire much of the show's
dna came from a 2013 movie called
clapping for the wrong reasons this is a
short that he and glover made about a
rap star moving from room to room in his
mansion drifting among the friends and
possessions he'd collected film school
rejects commented on the style of the
film writing compared to the high
concepts of some of mariah's music
videos it feels downbeat and almost like
an la version of mumble core micro
budget movies about creatives aimlessly
searching for themselves
you hate women
what
as if all of donald glover's
accomplishments weren't enough he also
made emmy's history when he received two
accolades for his work on atlanta
outstanding directing for a comedy
series as well as outstanding lead actor
in a comedy series glover became the
first black director to win in the
comedy category understandably it was
all a bit overwhelming i
i blacked out i don't know yeah like i
was not ready for that
he explained further saying he was in a
weird phase when he directed ban the
episode for which he won his emmy i was
doing a lot okay i was like a new father
okay writing other episodes and
directing and like cobbling this
together
he went on to say i'm really astonished
i was really shocked
one of the most bizarre and disturbing
episodes of atlanta was season two's
teddy perkins in this episode earn an
alfred's stoner philosopher friend
darius shows up to a large house outside
the city to pick up a free piano
there he encounters teddy perkins a
reclusive light-skinned face-lifted
former songwriter who is also played by
glover teddy insists on giving darius a
tour of the house which doubles as a
museum dedicated to himself and his
brother who lives in the attic suffice
to say things get very creepy very
quickly this is the furthest atlanta has
tipped into outright horror at least in
its first three seasons it was made all
the more unsettling when glover brought
his terrifying creation into the real
world apparently dressing is teddy
perkins at the 2018 emmy awards when he
was nominated for best actor in a comedy
series the word apparently is important
here because later in the evening glover
and teddy perkins were somehow
photographed together so who was sitting
in glover's seat internet sleuths
scoured the possibilities for months an
e-news report at the time quoted a
source claiming that the person under
the makeup was former snl cast member
jay pharaoh which pharaoh all but
confirmed in a 2021 video interview with
conde nast traveler had to be somebody
under there right
had to be somebody
three hours of makeup
in 2018 childish gambino released this
is america the song and its accompanying
hero mirai directed video was an
immediate viral hit it launched a
thousand think pieces scouring its every
lyric and image for meaning mirai
presents the bulk of the video as a
single take following glover through an
empty warehouse alternating between
moments of joy to moments of shocking
violence
likewise the music crashes buoyant
caribbean inspired rhythms up against
the haunting drone of its chorus glover
performed the song when he hosted
saturday night live that year and a
version of it also appeared in glover's
2019 short film guava island it also
became the first rap song to ever win
song of the year at the grammys glover's
work elicited a number of negative
reactions as well with some taking issue
with what they saw as his exploiting
black trauma and violence under the
guise of making art he's also been
accused of plagiarism on more than one
occasion in 2018 fans noted the
similarities between this is america and
rapper jace harley's 2016 song american
pharaoh harley declined to take legal
action apparently grateful just to be
part of the conversation in 2021 however
the rapper kid wes filed a suit against
glover on behalf of his own 2016 song
made in america glover maintains that
this is america predates both harley and
kid west's tracks
season 3 of atlanta premiered in march
2022 after a four-year hiatus during
that time one of glover's most high
profile gigs was the 2019 live action
remake of disney's the lion king
director john favreau and an army of
visual effects artists crafted a new
version of the classic 1994 animated
film and photorealistic cgi but
crucially retained the original film's
award-winning songs this meant that
glover playing simba had to sing the
well-known duet can you feel the love
tonight with nala played in the remake
by beyonce knowles carter glover was in
london filming solo a star wars story at
the time so he recorded his vocals
separately which as he joked on jimmy
kimmel live was probably a good thing
for him i did not want to be looking
into beyonce's eyes while doing
this
despite being an acclaimed recording
artist in his own right having to match
pipes with beyonce in the same room
would be a pretty nerve-wracking thing
in the segment kimmel suggests that it
was probably less intimidating to record
separately glover agrees i imagine it's
less intimidating playing basketball
with michael jordan yeah if you're at
home just throwing
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebrities are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one